the big news obviously this Monday
Washington changing their name sort of
you know the news came out over the
weekend that the name change was
imminent not an announcement that the
name will eventually change but an
actual change of the name that's what
was expected
we got a curveball from the franchise on
Monday morning when the statement which
was plastered with the current logo and
name announced that the name eventually
will be retired at some point down the
road when they actually picked a new
name so you know there was some
inconsistent reporting there'll be a
name change
as of Monday no the old name is going to
be retired as of Monday the truth
ultimately was nothing has happened by
way of changing the name other than the
announcement that at some point down the
road the name will change frankly it
feels like one last act of defiance by
owner Daniel Snyder kicking and
screaming he goes to into all caps never
o'clock when the name will change I mean
let's take a step back and think about
it whatever you think about the name
whether you think it's perfectly fine
you think an honors Native Americans
what do you think it needs to be changed
and whether you think it should have
been changed years ago there is
something odd about acknowledging that
the name needs to go but still keeping
the name isn't it I'm gonna be very
interested to see who in the media
continues to use the name that the team
has essentially admitted is not an
appropriate name and I threw that out
there on Twitter people like they
haven't admitted anything well yes they
have what what what if they declared
victory and retreated they have given it
up the only reason they're giving it up
is because they are getting pressure
from sponsors to give it up and the
reason they're getting pressure from
sponsors to give it up is because the
name is inappropriate the name is a
dictionary defined racial slur and in
this extended moment of racial reckoning
and awakening in America this is
something that had to happen it's a no
brainer it had to happen now why isn't
it happening right now it isn't
happening
right now because they don't have a new
name ready one of the reasons they don't
have a new name ready is because they've
been screwing around when it comes to
trademark rights we had a story
yesterday regarding all the squatters
out there who have filed for trademark
protection for names that could become
alternative names for the Washington
franchise
and other than an effort to squat on
warriors years ago that according to a
recent report the franchise has
abandoned which means someone else now
holds those rights there's nothing out
there suggesting that the team has laid
any foundation for trying to get the
appropriate protections for a new name
and a new logo and it's both the name
and the logo that are going away surely
they're gonna try to get this done
before training camp opens how awkward
this is to make it clear the name is
gonna change but to still keep the name
you've got to accelerate this effort and
my guess is there are some people in
league circles that are surprised by
this development the way this all got
started on Saturday Charles Robinson was
on radio with Clarence Hill in Dallas
and Charles said the name chess come on
Maisie Charles Charles said the name
change is imminent and that teams have
been instructed to be ready to scrub the
old name off of their websites well if
the new name isn't changing if the new
name is gonna remain in place until I
mean if the old names gonna remain in
place until the new name is selected
there's no reason to say any of that my
guess is and it's a somewhat informed
guess that Snyder went a little rogue
here keeping the name until the new name
is selected regardless it should not
take long and I think if anything is
posture this strange posture that Snyder
has tried to assume will result in even
more pressure to move quickly to get
this done right whatever check you have
to write do whatever you have to do to
get the trademarks for the name that you
have chosen and then move forward I also
thought it was a couple of other things
from the press release first dan Snyder
and Ron Rivera are the two coming up
with the new name I didn't know Ron
Rivera was an expert in branding
football teams I thought he was an
expert in coaching football teams how
does this responsibility get thrust on
to the head coach of the team who's
never even coached a practice for the
franchise are you kidding me why is Dan
Snyder using Ron Rivera in this capacity
I'm not saying Ron's not ultimately
equipped to do it but he's ottoman on
equipped to do
no more quick to pick a new brand than I
am than any fan is III don't get it
now hopefully that's just the posture
they're taking publicly and that behind
the scenes they're working with all the
appropriate experts but I'm not ready to
concede any points when it comes to this
franchise because as we always say
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things and when you look at that
statement that was issued today it is
soothing with dysfunction and take a
closer look at the rattling off of the
various constituents that will be
considered as the team pivots to a new
name sponsors aren't listed before fans
sponsors are listed before fans feels
like a little bit of a subtle middle
finger to the sponsors for being the
ones who have forced this and regardless
it's happening like if you're gonna do
it just do it what why are you doing it
in kind of a half-assed way why are you
just not ripping the whole name off and
leaving it blank
who cares if there's not a name there
nothing's happening right now training
camp doesn't open until July 28th at the
earliest get the name selected get rid
of the old name and get a new name in
place one last point and this is
something we're gonna be writing about
the P at PFT I heard about this over the
weekend and we need to give credit where
credit is due
apparently I'm told per sources the
Commissioner was heavily involved in
pushing and pushing and pushing behind
the scenes to get Snyder to do this we
always thought that what would happen is
there would be a group of owners who
would go to Dan and basically say it's
time like in the early 70s when the
group of Republican politicians went to
Nixon and said it's time something like
that but that didn't have to happen
no other owners had to get their hands
dirty here Roger Goodell fulfilling his
duties as the world's highest-paid pin
cushion taking on the responsibility
being the one who told Dan Snyder what
he needed to hear so between Goodell
from above and Ron Rivera from beneath
mulashi crunch timely reference for
those of you out there who grew up in
the 70s not so time there for anyone
else but the mulashi crunch results
dan Snyder finally crying uncle and
saying that he will do what he had said
in 2013 he would never do which has
changed the name look now I'm not trying
to gloat over this it's something that
needed to happen he was the right thing
to do it's been the right thing to do
for a long time I'm glad that has
finally happened I'm not going to get
into the why did it take you so long to
do this they're doing it I don't like
the fact that they're announcing that
they're doing it but not doing it yet
but soon enough
it will be gone and a new name will be
in its place and we'll see what it is
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports